was fragt wenn du dir ein spiel
ausdenken dürftest was dann auch
umgesetzt werden würde
wie würde es aussehen hallo peter schöne
frage ich würde ein spiel machen wo es
ist ein ganz klassisches third person
apg keine ahnung fängt doch erst mal an
ein zwei stunden alles ganz nett so sehr
dass sich die leute schon beschweren das
ist einmalig ist ich würde genau die
grenze abstimmen zwischen jetzt schalten
sie des spielausfalls so kommt schlecht
ist es wird auch immer schlechter und
plötzlich wendet sich aber das blatt und
die spielfigur selber sagt sich etwas
ist jetzt hier los ich das ist total
scheiße ich mag dieses spiel nicht mehr
und bricht aus der eigenen spiel wird
aus und der spieler muss plötzlich die
seite wechseln kriegt dann sozusagen von
dem programm dem vermeintlichen kriegt
er den auftrag scheiße uns ist der
protagonist abgehauen
der ist jetzt der ist einfach rechts
durch die spielwelt wand hat sich mit
einem ominösen schwert wasser gefunden
hat hat er sich ein loch in einen in die
spielwelt gemacht und deine aufgabe ist
es dann plötzlich diesem spiel charakter
wieder einzufangen das heißt du bist so
einen level editor und muss dann grenzen
bauen für ihn und der protagonist den
ihr vorher selber gespielt habt wird
aber immer stärker wie matschie nur ihr
müsst ihn dann halt entsprechend
einbauen so ein bisschen dungeon keeper
style
das ist das schön ich habe noch eine
andere idee ich weiß nicht wie viel zeit
ich habe andere idee kurzfassung wird
wahrscheinlich von diesen geklaut obwohl
nicht jugendfreie spieler ist am start
und wird automatisch aus versehen in die
videospiel hölle gezogen
in der videospiel hölle sind alle und
das sehr sehr viele gestorbenen
videospiel charaktere
das heißt du hast da ungefähr unzählige
zombie marios aus den verschiedenen ären
du hast unglaublich verschiedene sonics
lara crofts und sofort allen zombie form
und der junge kommt nach unten und merkt
aber okay die sind alle ganz schön böse
und zwar auf die menschen weil die
nämlich total ruchlos mit den
vermeintlichen von ups mit dem leben
umgehen und dann starten sie sozusagen
aus der videospiel hölle in die realität
in die echte realität und starten eine
attacke gegen
den verwöhnten videospieler der halt so
lapidar ich bin gestorben ich mache
meine savegames kein problem und starten
dagegen an und gewinnen das ist eine
andere idee das wird ein sehr teures
spiel und noch eine frage von open doors
was ist ein absolutes lieblings
videospiel heute und vielleicht auch aus
seiner kindheit
auch gott schwierig ich glaube aktuell
ich glaube es ist tatsächlich auch dark
souls dark souls das ist somit das
schwierigste und angenehmes ins spiel
zugleich dark souls das ist wirklich
damit das beste spiel also das gefällt
mir auf jeden fall seine beiden bin noch
gar nicht weit aber das ist so das ist
ein spiel wo ich mich wirklich darauf
vorbereitet ist zu spielen weil es zu
abgefahren ist ich glaube das ist hat
sich deswegen mein lieblingsspiel
ansonsten der klassiker starcraft habe
ich auch schon länger nicht mehr spielen
können
trials hd wir rufen dass auch wieder
nette kleinigkeiten die man so nebenbei
spielt aber sonst an den großen triple a
titel habe ich glaube ich nichts nichts
besonderes
monkey 2009 hast du eigentlich noch zeit
zum zocken
alemannia es leider sehr wenig geworden
muss ich sagen und ärgert mich auch
ärgert mich sehr aber es würde
hoffentlich wieder ein bisschen mehr
werden mal gucken wie so die nächste
zeit aussieht aber ich habe weniger zeit
zum zocken sehr schadet werden whisky
cola tv möchte wissen wäre für dich ein
normaler job außerhalb von tv und gaming
eine alternative gewesen wenn ja in
welche berufliche richtung wärst du
gegangen beziehungsweise hättest du
gehen wollen hallo whisky cola tv ich
glaube ich wenn ich jetzt nicht diesen
ganzen kram machen will den ich mache ja
ich hätte auf jeden fall auch vollkommen
los in einen normalen job zu gehen wobei
normal irgendwie schwierig ist
auszudrücken also ich erkenne das
durchaus anders ist alles sehr viel spaß
macht normaler job ich hatte lange zeit
das ist kitschig und spießer habe ich in
einem anderen video erklärt warum ich
ihn später bin ich hätte auch bock auf
lehrer gehabt kein witz oder auf ich
weiß nicht ich weiß nicht ich bin zu
schlecht ich hab zu wenig von der
arbeitswelt mitbekommen als dass ich was
jetzt sagen könnte ich habe sehr viel
jobbt auf jeden fall früher und ich habe
nichts gegen arbeit kann man sich selber
schlecht machen kann man sich selber
auch gut reden aber ich bin trotzdem
sehr sehr froh dass ich das privileg
gehabt diesen job hier zu machen den man
macht den man nicht wirklich definieren
kann arzt wäre schön gewesen bin ich zu
blöd zu und martin 97 hat folgende frage
macht ihr bei gm war nur keine rolle
mehr weil du die anderen nicht mehr
demütigen willst
ja das ist eine sehr schöne frage ich
bedanke mich sehr bei ihnen
ich muss dazu sagen rief ist ja
eigentlich nie jetzt derjenige der vorne
ist der penner
deswegen ist geht eine frage leider so
ein bisschen schießt über das ziel
hinaus aber ich muss sagen es gibt kein
wild mehr weil wir selber den anspruch
haben das dann auch wirklich gut zu
machen und auch schön zu machen und auch
spannend zu machen
und weil es tatsächlich so ist dass wir
immer wieder wenn wir das thema
aufbringen wir uns schon bei der spiel
entscheidung also welche spiele gespielt
wird da fangen wir schon an uns zu
streiten
es ist kein witz es wird ein spiel
genannt was aktuell rauskommt und dann
wird automatisch erklärt es ist klar
dass du das auswärts ist ich mache mir
nicht das verkompliziert das ganze mit
der produktion weil wenn du schon mit
mit dem streit entscheiden muss wann man
es macht das geht nicht also wenn man
sich auch nicht eigentlich welche spiele
man machen muss
aber wir haben noch einiges vor und
hoffen dass wir sehen kriegen